good morning everyone its pleasure to
welcome you all to this columbia world
leaders forum event we are joined today
by President Ford pahor of Slovenia who
is accompanied by a distinguished
delegation including among others the
permanent representative of Slovenia to
the United Nations in the head of the
cabinet of the President of Slovenia we
look forward to hearing president
befores remarks on the future of Europe
begun in 2003 on the initiative of
Columbia president Lee Bollinger the
world leaders forum has become an
invaluable experience and rare
opportunity for our students faculty and
staff to engage directly with the men
and the women who are addressing the
major challenges of the 21st century by
making it possible for the Columbia
community to enter into a structured
dialogue with foreign heads of state the
world leaders forum has become a leading
example of the open debate and due
consideration of opposing viewpoints
that really defines our academic
community we take is an article of faith
that through a free exchange of ideas
solutions will be found to the biggest
problems facing the globe today along
with the network of Columbia global
centers and the Committee on global
thought the world leaders forum plays an
essential role in making Columbia a
truly global University indeed it's
difficult to imagine that such an event
could be held in any other City or in
any other University permit me a few
words about the Herman Institute our
vibrant Centre for Russian Eurasian and
East European studies the Institute
brings together historians social
scientists and literature and art
scholars who study the many diverse
countries of the region as well as
politicians journalists artists writers
and other luminaries who participate in
our various conferences and events we've
been very fortunate to collaborate with
the world leaders forum for many years
featuring speakers speakers such as
Vladimir Putin of Russia President
Mikhail Saakashvili of Georgia and
Turkmenistan's President Gurbanguly
among others and this week we've already
heard from Estonian president Thomas
silvus and on Friday we look forward to
hosting Albanians prime minister at
Irama this would be a third visit of a
Slovenian leader and we've also welcomed
the famous Slovene philosophers Flavio
Dziedzic who spoke on several occasions
in this very building Slovenia gained
its independence from Yugoslavia in 1991
and largely avoided the worst violence
that plagued the remnants of the
Yugoslav Federation for nearly twenty
years after its independence Slovenian
joyed stability and prosperity serving
as a model of a robust democracy a
strong welfare state and a growing
economy in 2004 Slovenia joined both
NATO and the European Union and in 2007
it became the first post communist
country to adopt the euro at its
national currency and birudo hora played
a central role each of these decisions
like many other countries in Europe
Slovenia has been hard hit by the global
financial crisis after returning to
positive economic growth in 2010
Slovenia has struggled to restore
stability to the financial sector and
confidence to its consumers the last two
years have been especially difficult
when Slovenia has managed to avoid the
fate of Greece but the macroeconomic
situation remains fragile how Slovenia
and its fellow eurozone countries
resolve the current economic crisis is
an important issue not only for the
region but for the global economy as
well a Europe that continues on its
current path could further dampen hopes
for a rebound in global economic growth
and we look forward to hearing president
poor's remarks on his difficult issue
his excellency has been involved in
politics since he chaired the high
school student division of the Alliance
of socialists youth of Slovenia at age
15 he also made you'd in political
science so as a political scientist I
want to say that this agreement can be
quite valuable he has held a stunning
array of offices beginning in 1992 he
was a deputy in the Slovene National
Assembly and eventually rose to become
chairman of the Assembly in 2000 from
2004 to 2008 he was a member of the
European Parliament he then returned
Lavinia to become the Prime Minister of
a coalition government to post which he
held for four years and in 2012 he ran
for the presidency of Slovenia and won
by an overwhelming margin receiving 67%
of the vote in doing so he became the
youngest president of Slovenia and the
only person to have headed the
parliament the government and the
president say in Slovenian history
throughout its remarkable tenure in
Ljubljana and Brussels his voice has
been recognized and is an important
force for moderation mutual respect and
the integration of Slovenia into the
global community president Flores said
that he would like to keep his remarks
short so that he could take more
questions from the audience thinking
that the dialogue between the audience
and him will be the most lively part of
the discussion so we look forward both
to president before his remarks and to a
lively in vigorous question-and-answer
section so please join me in welcoming
president mejor
thank you very much good morning it is
much more than just privilege it is a
pleasure to address here at this
university the future of Europe as
Professor said my wish is to debate this
issue with you I will make a short brief
I hope not
boring introductory remarks and this and
then I would like to invite you to make
questions comments statements whatever
you want and I think this would be much
more interesting than just going through
my speech writing now let me start by
saying I have a very firm vision of the
future of Europe it is a vision of the
United States of Europe now not that
this is a very new idea it's there for a
couple of years but I think I'm the only
leader being Prime Minister president
among 28 countries of European Union
that would publicly say that he is in
favor of so you know so clear idea of
the future of Europe United States of
Europe now that would mean one
Parliament one government that would
mean one central bank one currency one
fiscal policy okay but but it's not and
it should not be a melting pot as maybe
United States of America
should not be would be complete disaster
if we would push for for United States
of Europe to be you know half a billion
population large replica of United
States of America no we have to respect
traditions by versions national culture
whatever you want
we have to keep it now for those who are
very much in favor as I am of United
States of Europe it is of crucial
importance to find out a right balance
between common institutions like
Parliament government central bank and
other institutions of federal state with
the absolute need for some sort of
sovereign you know States on the other
side sovereign relatively to maintain
the privilege of being different as
possible as much as possible now I know
it's difficult but this is the crucial
point how to make Europe successful
efficient but not to go too much into
the sovereign rights of 28 nations
because I think could happen once again
that at referenda people would vote
against the new constitution when it
comes if would be too much Brussels in
the Constitution now let me remind you
ladies and gentlemen that once we've
already tried to
to come to the Constitution European
Constitution at a time I used to be a
Speaker of the House as professor said
my fellow colleagues three of them have
joined at that time the so-called
convention of the fear of on the future
of Europe and I think the Chairman
ambassador the chairman of the
convention has been a former French
president former French president please
help me somebody
Jesus that does them sorry so at the end
of the convention sponsored by counsel
and and European Parliament this then
came with an idea that the whole
document would be Constitution okay and
then countries have the privilege to
decide to go for the referenda or to
decide on this in the house Slovenia has
voted on this in the house voted in
favor of but as you know France from
different reasons Netherlands for
different reasons voted against and the
first the very first attempt to go for
European Constitution failure I've been
very lucky to be later on elected to the
European Parliament I've taken my seat
in Constitutional Commission I've
participated very strongly to once again
come to a decision for a new convention
but as a politician I I should come to
the conclusion that at a time that has
not been absolutely you know possible in
meantime when I became a prime minister
the crisis from from Wall Street just
came to Europe and I do remember a very
first meeting of European Council
European Council as you know is a
council where all Prime Minister's or
head of states are represented you know
it is now probably the most influential
European body much more than Commission
and an in-house I know this is a very
sensitive remark but it's my Owen it's
my personal remark being for three years
a member of Council and four years
member of European vironment okay now
the crisis showed and this is very
important for the debate the crisis
showed that Lisbon Treaty Lisbon Treaty
as you know is a legal framework for
European Union at the moment which
basically has been a compromise between
a Constitution we want and the reality
we witnessed at the time the crisis has
shown that Europe could not survive
efficiently the time of crisis and and
time after would Lisbon Treaty I mean at
least in my opinion at least in my
opinion it is crystal clear that we have
to make step ahead now
my I think that after European elections
in May 2014 we will get a new Commission
and I think that at the end of the next
year at least out of my experiences
there will be a consensus among
institutions back in Europe
and among political parties within the
house in browsers to go once again for
convention and the future of Europe with
a very precise task once again to come
to the new reading of the Constitution
in my view in case that the majority of
Mme peace in Brussels would be
pro-european I think at the end of the
day we could witness for the very first
time some sort of United States of
Europe at least I will do whatever it
takes to achieve this maybe and and
probably compromises we will be there
but I think if anytime this time is it
is the right time to decide this way and
then it's fair to go and ask people
about their opinion also in Slovenia not
just the debate is in house but to go
for a referenda and to vote to deliver
some more sovereign rights from
Ljubljana to Brussels from Paris to
Brussels from from from from then hoc to
to to to
brushes or not now let me finish by
saying not just because of crisis but
because of a very very deep need of
Europe to be a global player in 21st
century to preserve peace to preserve
peace and stability in Europe to
maintain welfare in Europe the basic
condition is to deepen political
economic social and other dimension
dimensions of its own Union now could be
otherwise could be otherwise oh yeah I I
could not say that this will happen
nobody can say it and I know that there
are forces and this is democracy that
are absolutely against the idea of
Constitution that they are absolutely
against even of a status quo of Lisbon
tree they won't go out they want they
don't want to see Europe to be more more
Brussels and so on they blame Brussels
for all mistakes dealing with the crisis
and so on but I think in case we would
like to see a safe future for our
children in Europe as you know our
parents enjoyed peace and stability
after Second World War
we have to do this brave move to decide
upon a much more unified European Union
wheat as I said with tolerance to to
cultural and other differences among
nations and countries now the very last
sentence it is at the end of the day the
probability that this is not my wish but
it is a probability that in case we
would have a constitution which would be
some sort of constitution of United
States of Europe that some countries
would voted against could be not that I
would like to see but it could be and
even much more than that could be that
because of their economic performance
could not match with the criteria to be
the member of United States of Europe
that is why I will do without whatever
it takes
in my country to solve as quickly as
possible the crisis to turn back the
economy to growth to to stabilize our
economy within eurozone which is still a
little bit fragile I mean the eurozone
and the our own economy and that is why
I think it's extremely important for
small tiny Slovenia to be an open
society to be competitive society at the
same time
a country with strong social welfare but
prepared for the moment in the history
will occur definitely that at the moment
my people will go and vote on the new
constitution they will the majority of
them vote in favor of not against
because of the fear but will vote in
favor of because of hope as we voted in
favor back in 2004 because you know the
idea of independent Slovenia has been so
much linked with an European idea okay
ladies and gentlemen let me stop here I
have spoken very friendly and openly to
you and would be a huge privilege to me
if you would now make questions or
remarks or comments as Frank as I used
to be thank you so much
thank you very much
you've given us an awful lot to think
about if I could ask anybody who would
like to make question remark to please
come up to the microphone introduce
yourself briefly and if you could keep
your comments short and to the point
that would be much appreciated so that
we could ensure as broad a participation
as possible and we'll take turns
starting from this microphone first okay
hello thank you so much for coming and
speaking today at Columbia my name is
Andrew I'm a freshman here my question
or listening do you talk
I was really considering how in the
States we face some of the same
questions starting back in like 1787
with our Constitutional Convention and
discussing you know what is the role of
like the national government versus the
state government and I think that back
like throughout most of our history
we've been at the federal the National
has taken more of a prominent role and
people back in 1787 didn't not imagine
that we would have this kind of power
coming from Washington do you see that
we do now and so I'm just wondering what
what you think about that progression
how right now it's easy to say oh we're
gonna preserve the rights of the
sovereign nations in relation to what's
happening in Brussels but obviously once
you give some authority to Brussels then
there becomes that like constant
conflict as we've experienced in our own
history listen there must be practical
there are advantages and disadvantages
of federal state absolutely no doubt
about it but let me tell you out of
experience one thing you cannot run the
eurozone
with one european central bank and 17
fiscal policies you just cannot now that
is why we are now introducing banking
union and fiscal union but this is at
the edge of the Lisbon Treaty if we
would like to go on to be efficient for
you know Europe currency we have to have
normal institutions as in your case if
not it is another decision but that
would be a decision to step back once
again back to the to the history I just
don't want to see that because Europe
with with 28 nations out of European
Union for for you know Slovenia listen
is for me quite impossible to to imagine
that we would be capable to compete in
in 21st century in global economy
without being a member of eurozone we
won without being a member of the
European Union but it is difficult you
know to make necessary steps if the zone
if the your eurozone is not as you know
your currency zone you you have fed and
you have federal institutions and they
are responsible for for you know the
value and and the status of of demand we
have some problems back in Brussels in
Frankfurt so as you said some advantages
and disadvantages and but if I have to
choose I would go for a federal thank
you very much good morning mr. president
thank you for coming
my name is Simon and I'm a graduate
visiting student from Copenhagen Denmark
and I have this question for you when do
you think that Europe is ready for the
United States of Europe when I say
already I mean there the general
perception of the public I'm from
Scandinavia and no offense we're not
ready
Simon it's up to you and probably you
will go there and vote and you will
decide on this there is a question if
this decision will be at the referenda
at all I said I will do my best that
this will be a possibility let me tell
you Simon in case there will be not
enough political will to achieve this
draft constitution then I think the
status quo the Lisbon Treaty will just
not be enough for our family to go on I
don't just don't want to think about
consequences
I'm not saying in a couple of years I'm
say I'm talking about couple of decades
I have a son of 15 I enjoy a peaceful
and you know my parents enjoy a peaceful
time after Second World War I would like
him to to have his family in a peaceful
world and I think the condition for this
is some sort of deep integration but at
the at the end of the day I think it's
fair for Europeans to go and to vote on
it not just to ask a politicians no no
no no no we have to take this risk if
you want to ask people not to decide on
behalf of them and you will have this
vote and you will decide upon your
and destiny the future okay thank you
good morning my name is Dana I'm a
master's student at the School of
International and public affairs bearing
in mind the contributing role that
economic inequality between states
played in the breakup of Yugoslavia and
the fact that it's unlikely that smaller
younger nations will ever have the same
economic might as Germany for example
how would you envision a European United
States of Europe avoiding a similar fate
to that of Yugoslavia well a very good
question and out of our own experience
with former Yugoslavia I am in favor of
the United States Europe if I would not
have this dramatic experience with a
dissolution of former Yugoslavia I
probably would not be so keen about this
vision why because I think in case you
have a firm framework of democracy
respect of human rights rule of law the
possibility to decide to stay in order
to you know vote to go out I think in a
global world of 21st century it's much
more it's it's it's the best way for
small countries to be within such a
union because there is a global security
it is a common approach to
you know instruments how to be much more
competitive you know so in my experience
I cannot I can I cannot just imagine
that you know because of the lack of the
vision of European Union yes we have the
experience in eighties with former
Yugoslavia the lack of vision for
Yugoslavia as a democratic state federal
state as a European prior appian and so
a lack of that would happen with
European Union I think that the same in
a way this is a very strong you know
opinion on it but I think Europe will
avoid this I think I hope very much so I
know that somebody is asking why smaller
country would be in favour of such a
union with strong Germany in France and
Italy and but it's still better to be
with them in the family than to be
outside by yourself and competing in a
global economy be with technology with
you know
human you know most advanced approaches
and so uh this is my very personal
response to your excellent question
as you know Slovenia with Croatia has
launched a so-called birth the process
initiative so to keep good relations to
keep a political dialogue among
countries in Western Balkans Bosnia
Kosovo Serbia Montenegro Macedonia we
would like to keep with them this
optimism on the common European future
now this is maybe the answer to your
question let me say so why do you think
Bosnia Serbia Kosovo Macedonia are so
much in favour to be in European Union
having this you know dramatic experience
with the war down there after the fall
down for me was nada
just because it's better to be within
Union than outside so their aspiration
to be in the Union is the answer to your
question okay thank you very much hello
thank you for coming my name is Jorge
I'm currently a freshman at Columbia
College and I just wanted to say that I
totally agree with you in terms of the
incompatibility of a monetary union
without a political union but how would
you respond to the opposing argument
that countries instead leave the
monetary union or make an arrangement
similar to the UK in which they have
their own currency or
their own central bank well once again
III dunno what I wish I don't know what
would happen what I wish is that I that
that the London would would stay within
the Union that the Brits will vote in
favor of staying within Union even more
that once United Kingdom will be part of
eurozone but could be a completely
different story if the people of this
great nation will vote against the next
referendum so it's going to be a very
very difficult debate there how to
proceed I've met several British Prime
Minister's from Labour Party from
Conservative Party all action gentlemen
I think everybody is in favor of
European Union but on the other side
they know that London City at the moment
is not prepared to even debate you know
the possibility to enter the monetary
union so it's going to be very difficult
even more difficult for them to decide
how to proceed with with this European
idea then maybe my country for my people
as I said I don't know how they will
decide I do know what I wish
it's it's going to be a very very
difficult decision let
say Georgia to you that it's going to be
a difficult moment of time for Europe in
next couple of years now we can just
assume the decision but let me say once
again status quo is already getting back
you know so but I'm satisfied that
people will decide upon their destiny
what is needed is the leaders to step in
front of them and speak in favor of the
Union that that I think it's important
that is in in a way the reason why I'm
here that you would see that there are
politicians back in Europe that would
speak very frankly in favor of United
States of Europe and it is not that
Georgia I would have a very firm answer
to every question how this you know the
United States should look like but there
is at least a vision you know we have to
debate now let us wait and see if your
kingdom will be a part of this debate or
not I would like to see Britain very
much to be within the family it is very
very important country thank you hi
thank you for coming to speak with us
today my name is MIA done I'm a senior
at Columbia College I spent a year in
London taking a nationalism course and
there we debated whether European Union
led to a decline or an increase in
nationalist sentiments and if we were to
move towards the United States of Europe
do you foresee being European replacing
being Slovenian or being German or being
British you know what is your experience
out of being there for a year what do
you think it is a general atmosphere
among Brits on European perspective I
think that
there definitely is some negative
sentiments towards being European the
Brits are very fiercely proud of who
they are and their history and I think
they'll be able to balance it if they do
join the European Union what are your
thoughts
listen I can't imagine how difficult it
is for four official London to decide on
this extremely sensitive issue because I
do know how difficult it is for my
country but it's even more difficult for
London than for Ljubljana why because
you know being a member of United States
of Europe would mean for for London even
less direct involvement in world's
affair would be you know complete
different approach to economy to global
policy to international politics out of
sentiments of you know important history
would be very difficult for people to
imagine that some some other guys from
Europe would represent London at the
Security Council for example let us
think about it in not in couple of years
and in a couple of decades within the
framework of reform of United Nations
and Security Council so it's very
difficult it's very difficult to to
answer this question I think at the end
of the day this is not just my wish but
I would I would take a risk do to call I
think the majority will vote in favor of
I think the risk of staying out
is absolutely - too difficult to take me
to thank you thank you very much for
coming today
my name is Sasha and I'm a freshman at
Tanya college and I was wondering how
you would imagine in the United States
of Europe addressing foreign policy
whether the United States or as separate
countries
so from tougher to toffee well listen
let us say some encouraging encouraging
words about at least attempts of
European Union to be in global
international politics with one voice we
have high representative for foreign and
security policy Lady Ashton listen would
be quite impossible to imagine such an
institution 10 or 15 years ago now it's
there the institution and the person so
the American foreign minister could make
a phone call to European Union and he
has a number of the person who is
responsible for European perspective of
doable policy now it is quite clear that
this is just a beginning of common
foreign policy but at least it is a
beginning so I think this shows that the
general common sense at least among
politicians back in Europe that there is
a strong need for reform of European
Union and to get step-by-step maybe to
Union as I've spoken about European
United Nation the United States of
Europe so basically as I said one
Parliament which would then elect a
government this is not the case at the
moment you know that the case of the
moment is that basically Council would
propose to Parliament a gentleman or
lady for a commission president the
Parliament would vote then on confidence
and then every country would then get a
seat within the Commission with one
commissioner this is close but not
enough for an efficient body which would
be executive a political body of
European Union on the other side you
have council the council is composed
from prime ministers and and head of
states in case of france or latvia
cyprus i think and this council at least
in my view during the crisis has gained
much more power than before so because
it has been you know the position to
take the decisions and i do remember we
have had meetings from 8 you know p.m.
and
5 6 a.m. in the morning about different
perspectives of Greece prizes Portugal
Spain and others so I cannot be more
specific about this you know
institutional dimensions of the future
in Constitution for United States of
Europe but there is at least a picture
of our fate
so Sasha this is my response to your
very good question Thank You president
pahor it's a pleasure to have you here
today I'm a PhD student at Columbia but
I'm German and the question is probably
going to get even tougher now so we all
heard Pam on phone Rompuy the President
of the European Council talked two days
ago and the same issue is about the
United States of Europe came up and he
strongly said that it will never be the
United States of Europe because there's
just too many different countries too
many different national like ideas too
many cultures and too strongly defended
that so obviously you have a different
perspective
and well we all know that this has been
the hot topic in discussion about the
European Union like the details of the
integration ever since its inception so
I would like to ask you what would be
some of your like personal sort of
opinions and concrete ideas you would
have as to in which areas we need deeper
integration which areas should be rather
left to like national sovereignty and
how would you go about that right now
with all due respect to council
president headman Bunder employees my
very good friend not just a colleague
and really a very very good an honest
person
a brave politician
I disagree with him but you have to
understand that as a council president
would not now loudly speak about United
States security if Herman Van Rompuy
would say this would be some sort of you
know huge debate but on the other side
the Commission president probably
outlined Commission President Barroso at
one of the last speeches in Strasbourg
in in European Parliament mentioned this
strong need as he said so I think let me
let me answer this way just a couple of
years before the fall of berlin wall
would you meet a lot of people that
would say that soviet union will
disappear no but it happened it will
happen we have to wrap up i want to
thank the students for their provocative
questions i'm not surprised I'm always
impressed by the level of discussion at
these events and I also want to thank
the president for the frankness of a
speech and the clarity of his vision
which makes it very easy to ask good and
important and substantive questions
unfortunately president poor has to
battle New York City traffic to get over
to the United Nations or I'm sure he
would be glad to continue this
discussion but we are very glad that he
made time from his very busy schedule to
come and I thank you all for coming and
please join me in giving a big round of
applause and appreciation of President
pahoa of the public opinion